you ready
come on
yeah i know it kind of sucks i want this
side
so first we need to tell them what the
show is going to be about these were
only
like the outtakes okay
my knee is at you
yeah
it's empty the premise of the show is
kind of like reverse
and you stop chewing this one and i'm
like i hear you wait wait wait did you
smell that
tell this is burning i
so the first thing that i did instead of
trying to find one in my apartment
building was go to amazon to see if i
can have one overnighted it smells like
fire
maybe something outside let me smell
outside we should
do you remember patty cakes yeah
daddy cake wait no i know that way don't
wait that was like miss merry map do you
remember that
no
wow we need it this is what happens all
day
all day every day i'm like jenna we
should do something then we start
talking about something and then we end
up doing this
we need to get like a topic trending
topics no
okay hold on i'll tell you the training
topics are currently right now um
i love my dad even though these are
stupid
fatty cake is dressing oh my god oh my
god
shut up did you see that
oh my god no one really is i swear to
you
shut up shut up you've been looking at
training topics all day i was
okay that's weird no that's seriously i
swear to god that's freaking really
strange i don't believe you what is this
why
how did that conversation even start
about because if you were clapping and
then i was like
you're that's how my brain works my
brain is like trending topics on twitter
oh i'm sweating
three hour no
oh my god look at that oh
hey mom i'm just a young basilisk
how's room huh oh
did you hear that no
okay uh bye bye ow
i need a new twitter picture i'm gonna
take one right now okay
oh wait what do you want me to do
no stop